hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry of fear okay as someone
suggested so kindly in the comments you
can just jump through this window here
oh man I am an idiot okay anyway I jump
through the window and now I'm guessing
that I'm getting close to the Ronald
Street exit or something I don't know
I'm not exactly sure but I'm ready for
anything
monsters scary stuff all pareto just
bring it on oh oh I'm not ready for this
okay like bunch who's there oh ah time
for creepiness
another apartment who's there
I know they're gonna spawn one right
behind me oh boy oh boy of all I dropped
my syringes are you kidding me what the
hell
really Wow I did not think that I would
be this that's stupid
well then what the hell have I been
doing well when did I drop my syringes
or maybe I just used them all and ran
out all right um I don't think I have
much in the way of shotgun ammo left
yeah I'm completely out of jail so I'm
just gonna drop it for now look at this
because eventually I'm gonna needle okay
here we go ha get the upstairs this
isn't good go downstairs
all night won't budge it's right here
probably a bad sign
okay jitter in the stomach I know not
suicidal in fallujah ghin nope you can't
pull that trick on me you're you're not
there are you you're not there anymore
gone aren't you lady you're gone lady in
white you're not so scary once you get
to know ya Oh get out here okay you got
it here I came in hmm Oh unlock the lock
okay
that must have been the Ronald Street
exit cool oh hello crazy are you kidding
me right
matter buddy can't find his way to me
pathfinding rules
oh hello there just hold still wait I
need to reload Wow no point what's that
buddy there's so many you guys steps I
did unlock okay cool go on the right way
finally two clips of ammo to a gun that
I don't have but are they loading me up
for a boss I have to wonder
Oh not down you guys where are ya
[Music]
okay here we go oh I need health please
don't be the monster the bottom that
kills me okay I see you I see you I see
that other guy that can't hide from me
I'm too smart and too handsome
hang on I gotta reload hey step back I
see you you guys [ __ ] see you dancing
bug again it cannot be so quick on the
draw
[Applause]
okay I'm okay I need to reload my clock
man is so inconvenient to use a gun dark
I'm not again and there it goes now I
have bullets more up keep pulling on my
own again cuz it's light up there oh no
mom boy huh it's quiet it's really quiet
they usually make it quite when they're
about to Jeremy yeah but it gonna work
they can't scare me uh-huh
back in the city
why did I need to get this fuse
I didn't tell me to get the fuse
something heavy is blocking the door I
don't like this too many unanswered
questions
like fudge our
le don't like it don't knock
didn't work guys
okay the letter here
[Music]
I enough three talk window okay so it
must be for these here Oh
how about the one with blood in it yep
there we go
why would I go in the one where there's
blood of all the windows really wait a
minute am i back in the apartments yeah
[Applause]
I went full circle a I still don't know
what my objective is might not be this
way
cuz there's not any enemies in front of
me I think I know you know what I'm
thinking remember in this apartment
there was chained
fill them with bullets please I am
supposed to go this way because there
are monsters that's general rule follow
the rule oh oh oh
doors not chained up anymore Oh No
[Music]
anger dude I got a gun
what the hey where did you come from I'm
running out of ammo and all my guns I
think two guys there who's that knocking
knock knock
there we go
hello
hammering oh hello everybody
I'll leave you alone you leave me alone
[Applause]
same nose completely out of ammo
yes first it
oh no oh I gotta cut it here guys thank
you
Saved by the Bell run out of time so
thank you so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next part
bye bye